researchers have discovered a piece of
20 million year old petrified wood on
the greek island of lesbos they knew it
was from lesbos because it's
double-ended oh
did you pass across before this
yeah what do you think two three years
no it's gotta be more than that
about three years
so
officials at the cleveland zoo have
announced that one of their critically
endangered black rhinos is pregnant
still no word on if she plans to keep it
the location of sex island which is a
four day drug fueled event featuring
prostitutes and an exclusive resort has
been revealed to be an island off the
coast of trinidad and tobago this
according to the plane ticket i saw in
shae's hand
[Applause]
country music star morgan wallen had his
recording contract suspended after a
video surfaced of the singer using the
n-word hmm wonder who we learned that
from
german researchers have recorded the
shortest interval of time for an event
to begin and end the event finished so
quickly scientists have named it che
so we're making each other read jokes
live on air that the other person has
never seen before
las vegas is opening a pop-up vaccine
site in a strip club and don't worry the
strippers say the vaccine is a lot like
michael che
very quick and you can barely feel it go
in
[Applause]
a student in texas who is nicknamed
white lightning
set a high school record by running the
100 meter dash in 9.98 seconds
coincidentally people call me white
lightning because i also finish in under
10 seconds
oh boy a 102 year old woman from new
york who survived the 1918 spanish flu
has now beat coronavirus twice but sadly
she was no match for my car
a new poll shows that 75 of lgbtq voters
support joe biden but zero percent of
them support joe biden guessing what the
b t and q stand for
hey well we're still five weeks away
from easter but earlier tonight a man
came back from the dead
a man in arizona is claiming that he can
relieve sinus pressure in his nose by
masturbating he first made the claim
while police were removing him from the
bus
for the first time in 146 years it has
not snowed in chicago during the months
of january and february or all the
snowflakes were shot before they reached
the
ground police in austria report that
more than one million bees have been
stolen from a local park or and hear me
out they just flew away
well a new report ranks the new york
city subway system as the best in the
country
this was according to masturbating hobo
monthly
experts are saying that cape town south
africa will completely run out of water
on april 12th meanwhile in the rest of
the world
a massachusetts couple whose son was
born during the super bowl has named him
brady while an atlanta couple whose son
was born during the super bowl has named
him son of a [ __ ]
h m has apologized after using a black
child to model a sweatshirt with the
logo coolest monkey in the jungle worse
the shirt was made by the saddest child
in the sweatshop
i said worse
this week construction began on a new
hip-hop museum in the bronx
and i know that we've had a lot of fun
with me reading racist jokes that
michael writes for me but because our
country is already divided enough i'd
like to use my platform to say something
that everyone of all races can agree on
witty helen is innocent
pope francis ended the vatican summit by
promising the catholic church would
confront the clergy sex abuse head on
instead of their usual way face down ass
up
[Applause]
amazon ceo jeff bezos claims he was
blackmailed by the publisher of the
national enquirer which he said
threatened to publish semi-nude selfies
of him and if you're curious about what
bezos penis looks like here's an
exclusive preview
kamala harris will become the first vice
president to be featured as a wax figure
at madame tussaud's wax museum while joe
biden is the first wax figure to become
president
a family in australia has discovered
what is believed to be the world's
oldest message in a bottle which was
thrown into the sea over 130 years ago
by a then middle-aged bernie sanders
i feel like if you're going to be a
white supremacist you should look like
colin at least right
what i mean if
if i were trying to prove the
superiority of the aryan race i wouldn't
use stephen miller's face i'd use yours
for the second year in a row the
happiest city in the country is naples
florida while the least happy city is
once again puppy funeral minnesota
do a split screen of colin and stephen
miller for one second
audience by a round of applause
who do you think hitler would want to be
friends with
stephen miller or colin nixon jokes
that's not my middleman
how is no one keeping track of how many
guns people own there is a real law in
texas that says it's illegal to own more
than six dildos
and i get why no one needs that many
if you have more than six dildos it's a
clear sign you are training for
something awful
[Music]
i mean
every customer's like i'll take one cup
of joey
uh all the baristas are buffed shirtless
guys i can't wait to check it out said
the health inspector
said colin please don't tell scarlet you
saw me here
a british songwriter is suing you too
claiming that the band stole one of his
songs though i don't like the
songwriter's chances because his lawyer
is working pro bono
insisted on telling that matt lauer the
former today show host gave a female
colleague a sex toy as a gift which is a
bad thing so i guess that means i should
return the secret santa gift i got for
colin
it's double-sided
a new report finds that as people move
into formerly wild areas of africa human
activity is disrupting chimpanzee
culture incidentally chimpanzee culture
is also what my grandpa calls hip-hop
[Applause]
researchers are testing a new method to
treat cancer by injecting the cells with
the herpes virus so good news if you've
ever had sex with me you might have to
cure for cancer
well you're not gonna like this
the chief of the cherokee nation is
calling on car maker jeep to stop using
the tribe's name on its vehicles so jeep
has agreed to change the name to wow the
ancho mimo mobile
new research shows that the first thing
59 of people eat on their chocolate
easter bunnies are the ears while the
rest are like me and go straight for
that butt
[Applause]
military officials have announced that
they will increase missions to train
advise and assist troops in the african
nation of niger the focus on niger is
viewed as a direct challenge to
president trump's autocorrect
an obese monkey in thailand named
godzilla has been sent to a special
facility to lose weight
officials realized the monkey was
overweight when a bunch of black guys
kept hitting on it
a new study shows that the average
american touches their mobile device
more than two thousand times a day
only two thousand times said my penis
warner brothers is producing a new movie
in which superman is black and a black
superman actually makes a lot of sense
when you remember that superman was
abandoned by his parents as a big
a new report shows that hurricane flores
was the wettest in history the previous
record for wetness was set on the
opening night of magic mike